et avec nous pour ce dernier club de la
saison pierre Jacquemin bonjour Pierre
bonjour Merci d'être la rédacteur en
chef de Politis et l'éditorialiste
politique de Munich de mon vallon
bonjour Dominique merci d'être avec nous
Audrey évidemment nous a rejoint bonjour
on va parler des inquiétudes à la veille
du 14 juillet va-t-on voir les émeutes
repartir Gérald Darmanin annonce un
dispositif de sécurité exceptionnelle
Emmanuel Macron promet d'agir avec la
plus grande détermination en cas de
débordement et puis Emmanuel Macron
saisira-t-il la main tendue par Laurent
Wauquiez ce matin dans Le Figaro il
appelle le président de la République à
une forme d'union sacrée à dépasser
temporairement les divisions et
s'entendent sur de grands textes alors
cette prise de position changera-t-elle
la donne chez les républicains vous nous
direz ce que vous en pensez puis à la
fin de ce club on prendra de la hauteur
on verra comment la Patrouille de France
se prépare au défilé aérien de demain
mais d'abord on regarde l'actualité dans
nos régions
[Musique]
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale et
des télévisions locales on va à Rennes
retrouver Stéphane Bernier bonjour
Stéphane merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
directeur de l'information de TV Rennes
Stéphane on en parlait dispositif de
sécurité maximale pendant ces prochains
jours ce soir demain pour encadrer les
festivités du 14 juillet c'est ce qu'a
annoncé hier Gérald Darmanin dans quel
état d'esprit se prépare les festivités
du côté de Rennes
et bien Oriane vigilance et prévoyance
pour ses festivités du 14 juillet 14
juillet qui démarrera ce soir à Rennes
avec un feu d'artifice qui sera tiré à
23h15 mais vous l'avez dit énormément de
force de police de gendarmerie
sapeurs-pompiers on parle de 130 000
personnes pour ces deux jours avec des
moyens un peu exceptionnels car la
capitale bretonne ne souhaite pas
revivre vraiment ces scènes de violence
et de dégradation que l'on a pu subir
ces dernières semaines alors en plus un
événement s'est invité le 5 juillet
dernier les forces de gendarmerie ont
fait une saisie record
2,7 tonnes de mortiers d'artifice là a
été trouvé à Guichen c'est au sud de
Rennes c'est un convoi polonais qui
avait envoyé cette masse de mortier et
ses engins explosifs donc très grande
vigilance sur le territoire alors que la
première ministre a pris un arrêté pas
de bandelcool pas de vente d'engins
pyrotechnique et bien le préfet de
région Emmanuel Berthier a été encore un
peu plus loin en demandant de ne pas
avoir de produits chimiques ou explosifs
pas de bord d'armes mais également pas
d'alcool sur la voie publique voilà un
peu la tonalité de ces festivités du 14
juillet on veut vraiment faire très
attention et vraiment réagir dès le
moindre problème alors sachez juste si
vous venez ce soir en Bretagne feu
d'artifice au stade de la bellangerie à
Rennes à 23h15 à Saint-Malo sur la plage
du Sillon demain vendredi tout comme à
Fougères vraiment tiré depuis le château
quant à la ville de Vitré elle n'a pas
souhaité cette année proposée à ses
habitants et au spectateurs un feu
d'artifice
merci Stéphane juste elle a pas souhaité
le proposer en lien avec ses émeutes
c'est ça
de problèmes on sait que vitré est une
le feu d'artifice est tiré dans le
centre-ville il y a un château il y a de
vraiment de très vieux bâtiments classés
donc vraiment attention pas de problème
pas d'incendie et on a préféré remettre
à l'année prochaine et festivités merci
Stéphane merci Stéphane Meynier d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin durant toute
cette saison vous retrouvez évidemment
avec grand plaisir à la rentrée merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous alors
Stéphane nous le rappelait un dispositif
annoncé hier par Gérald Darmanin
dimanche dans le Parisien Elisabeth
borne avait déjà annoncé des mesures sur
pas de vente pas de transport de mortier
l'inquiétude est maximale au
gouvernement de nouvel an
l'inquiétude est forte et c'est le moins
qu'on puisse attendre du gouvernement
vous savez ce qui me paraît se passait
c'est que au fond plus les jours passent
par rapport aux journées ou à la journée
enfin même au pluriel des meute et de
pillages plus au fond les Français ont
prennent conscience de la gravité de ce
qui s'est passé
à ce moment-là et au fond leur cri du
cœur c'est plus jamais ça mais c'est une
chose de le dire c'est une autre de le
ressentir après concrètement on ne sait
pas on sait pas et donc il y a des
mesures qui ont été prises par Elisabeth
borne et par Gérald Darmanin ils ont
raison à Pierre Jacquemin ce sont les
bonnes mesures
écoutez franchement quand on vient de
vivre des moments comme ceux que l'on a
vécu quand on s'aperçoit que ce qui a
été vrai par le passé dans les quartiers
populaires c'était tendu à d'autres
types de population étalées jusque dans
les centres urbains
certes il faut sans doute de la fermeté
dans ce que nos services sont justice
peuvent apporter oui encore faut-il que
cette justice ne soit pas non mais
certes il le faut très bien soit la même
pour toutes les personnes qui sont
absolument amenés à être devant les
tribunaux ce sentiment de justice à deux
vitesses
pour rester sur votre sujet voilà on va
rester sur le sujet pour que au moins
sur cette dernière émission nous soyons
à peu près d'accord avec Dominique non
mais quand il sait quand on voit tout ce
qu'il s'est passé je sais bien que ce
gouvernement nous a dit à plusieurs
reprises qui n'étaient pas de temps le
temps de l'analyse n'était pas
maintenant mais si je pense que on se
pose la question de savoir si ce soir
demain il risque d'y avoir des révoltes
dans les dans les rues de France
c'est pas c'est pas une échéance aussi
court thermiste que l'on doit réfléchir
le gouvernement devrait se positionner
sur
une échelle de dizaines d'années et
parce que ce qui se passe dans les
quartiers c'est tous les jours la
violence ressentie par les gens qui
vivent dans les quartiers elle est
réelle tous les jours donc nous on ne
voit et on ne commente que des faits
quand il y a des violences quand les
voitures brûles c'est le seul moment où
les médias s'intéressent à peu près ce
qui se passe dans la vie de ces
quartiers or tous les jours la violence
elle est présente dans ces quartiers
donc ça ne peut pas s'arrêter et demain
et où ce soir c'est sur du très long
terme que l'on doit réfléchir et
franchement même même Emmanuel Macron
quand il commence à être président de la
République prend une décision qui va
être à mon avis catastrophique pour la
suite de la vie des quartiers populaires
souvenez vous à l'été 2017 il prend la
décision de couper 10% des budgets
alloués aux associations des quartiers
populaires ça commence là l'histoire
c'est pas parce que Emmanuel Macron pris
sa décision qu'on en est là aujourd'hui
qui est mort et on en est à parler des
pillages c'est ça qui est dramatique
c'est qu'on paye
quand même c'est pas un sujet tabou mais
ce qui jamais vu on devrait quand même
s'interroger sur les raisons pour
lesquelles un jeune homme aujourd'hui
est mort dans les conditions dans
lesquelles on aujourd'hui
et tout le monde a dit son émotion et à
quel point c'était scandale parce que
moi ce que je trouve dramatique alors
que je trouve
dramatique ce que je trouve dramatique
c'est que certes il faut parler d'ordre
certes il faut parler de sécurité tout
le monde a besoin de sécurité tout le
monde peut pouvoir aller chercher son
pain emmener ses enfants dans la cour
d'école ou de ses enfants dans le faire
le manège en bas de son immeuble ou en
bas de chez soi tout le monde mais tant
qu'on ne voudra pas voir ce qui ce qui
sous nos yeux même les organisations
internationales le disent l'ONU le dit
le racisme dans la police combien de
fois un jeune de quartier est-il arrêté
par jour par des faciès combien de fois
pourquoi les jeunes des quartiers
n'acceptent pas aux mêmes emplois que la
jeunesse de France 20% des habitants de
20% de la jeunesse de France vit dans
ses quartiers pourquoi les services
publics ne sont pas aussi bien dotés y
compris ceux de la police dans les
quartiers populaires tant qu'on ne
s'attaquera pas à ça il y aura toujours
ce sentiment de relégation qui créera de
la colère juste un mot que vous êtes ce
qui n'est pas le cas formellement un
lecteur du maire de Lyon puisque le
maire de Lyon n'a pas hésité à dire nous
sommes tous un peu racistes c'est quand
même énorme la raison il a il a raison
je vous avais bien situé le wife on va
arrêter d'être ma zone quand même non je
pense qu'il a raison on va combattre les
les mots Maui là où ils sont les drames
quand ils surviennent et on va on va
faire en sorte que que la France reste
la France mais nous sommes tous un peu
racistes c'est une déclaration les plus
scandaleuses que j'ai entendu 13 morts
en l'espace de 3 ans 13 morts en
l'espace de 3 ans sur des présomptions
de
temps OK
il s'appelle amine Naël Abdelkader la
liste des victimes de du trafic de
drogue je vous parle d'un sujet
après on va revenir au festivités du 14
juillet est-ce que ça justifie un une
mort et est-ce qu'on peut se poser la
question de pourquoi il s'appelait
Abdelkader pourquoi ils étaient noirs
pourquoi ils étaient d'origine arabe
pourquoi on peut se poser cette question
est-ce qu'on peut écouter les organismes
internationaux qui disent à la France
essayer de faire en sorte que votre le
racisme dans les forces de l'ordre soit
combattu il faut écouter il faut pas il
faut pas être dans le démissionner dans
le déni on va continuer comme ça
un vrai problème il faut l'aborder je
suis d'accord les mots compte les mots
compte et généralisations les amalgames
aussi ça compte et c'est ça qui me
scandalise mais les organisations
internationales il s'agit de petites
branches d'une organisation
internationale appelons-le par son nom
d'une petite d'une non d'une petite
branche tenue par des amis de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon d'accord est-ce que contenu du
contexte et de l'état du pays Emmanuel
Macron aurait dû prendre la parole
demain de mon ballon est-ce qu'il fait
une erreur de ne pas s'adresser aux
Français en ce jour de fête nationale
une fois de plus il doit être je
l'imagine je sais pas ce confidences il
doit être ravi de prendre à contre-pied
le monde médiatique le monde politique
au médiatique qui s'apprêtait à gloser à
partir de ce qu'il allait dire ou pas
dire de ce qu'il allait oublier dans ses
propos etc il est prêt pour toi
on a eu l'épisode de l'épisode de
Elisabeth borne va partir va être
remplacée on a eu 15 jours on a parlé
que de ça maintenant il a pris ça
attendez je pense que c'est du bon sens
c'est tout il parlera plus vite encore
qu'on l'imagine si les choses se passent
mal ce que je ne veux pas croire et il
parlera forcément dans pas longtemps
mais il faudra intégrer ce qui se sera
passé
c'est marrant parce que le bon sens de
Dominique des visiblement pas le bon
sens de Pierre Jacques marin donc c'est
étonnant cette référence au bon sens me
fera toujours beaucoup beaucoup rire
moi je trouve ça pas mal il y a un bon
sens par habitant dans ce pays par
habitant de peine vous voyez bien que le
bon sens à partager un peu la même
approche ça s'appelle les idées ça
s'appelle les idées le débat
démocratiques donc on appelait au bon
sens
oui mais vos idées ne sont pas forcément
le bon sens enfin bref peu importe mais
est-ce que ne sont pas forcément les
fautes mais on est d'accord
est-ce que Emmanuel Macron aurait dû
parler c'est toujours utile dans ton un
président de la République c'est
compliqué ou en tout cas donner des
éléments de compréhension et de réponse
après les événements comme ceux que l'on
vient de vivre
toutes les strates de la société
française ont été impactées de cette
manière par cette par ce qu'il s'est
passé donc oui encore faut-il qu'il y
ait des choses à dire il s'agit pas
juste de dire comme certains de ces
ministres l'ont dit le temps n'est pas
l'analyse il faut punir voilà il faut
sortir des réponses qui sont trop
faciles donc effectivement peut-être que
s'il doit prendre deux trois jours de
plus pour pouvoir s'exprimer et attendre
que c'est sûr que c'est s'ils doivent
s'il doit avoir un discours de concorde
ce soir ou demain soir et que dans la
même soirée la France parce que voilà
voilà
il était sorti par la porte la fenêtre
de la stratégie et la communication
politique
qui puisse s'exprimer comme le fait
comme le volet tradition ça vous manque
il parle pas le 14 juillet mais
peut-être le 17 le 18 et 17 ça va vous
frustrer non chers amis
encore Macron toujours Macron toujours à
côté de la plaque là vous allez être un
peu plus moi j'ai toujours attentif dès
qu'il y a une parole du président
fâcheuse mais mais la contenu de la
crise que l'on vient de traverser oui je
pense que ça va parler est attendu toute
façon le problème n'est pas Macron
seulement mais l'ensemble des Français
face à une crise qui est gravissante
et qu'après la parole c'est Laurent ok
ce matin dans un entretien accordé au
Figaro il parle des selon urbaine Audrey
il donne l'impression qu'il veut prendre
un peu de hauteur oui certains
pourraient même voir cela comme une
préparation à une potentielle
candidature pour 2027 Laurent Wauquiez
se rappelle à notre bon souvenir et si
tout de même trois philosophes Platon
Bourdieu et Derrida le professeur
Legendre et même Georges Clémenceau pour
expliquer et commenter les violences qui
ont suivi la mort du jeune Naël de la
hauteur et des termes chocs selon lui
ces émeutes sont le symptôme
spectaculaire d'un mal beaucoup plus
profond qui touche notre pays la
désintégration de l'État et de la nation
et d'ajouter les deux seules figures de
l'autorité qui subsistent dans les
quartiers sont les caïdes et l'imam le
président de la Région Auvergne
Rhône-Alpes qui fait aussi des
propositions il appelle à l'union sacrée
autour du chef de l'État sans volonté de
coalition précise-t-il juste après mais
autour de plusieurs grandes idées je
vais vous donner la citation exacte
c'est un peu long mais ça permet de bien
se rendre compte dans l'intérêt de la
nation il revient au président de la
République de mobiliser une forme
d'union sacrée autour de mesures
décisives ma démarche n'est en aucun une
démarche de coalition de négociation ni
de compromission mais après une telle
crise nous devons être capable de
dépasser temporairement les divisions et
de nous entendre sur quelques mesures
fortes soutenues par une écrasante
majorité des Français il en appelle
aussi à faire appel au Parlement ou même
un référendum on va parler de ces
propositions dans quelques secondes
d'abord Dominique mais sur cette phrase
cet appel à l'union sacrée c'est
surprenante la part de Laurent Wauquiez
c'est très nouveau en tout cas c'est
totalement nouveau ça part mais il a si
on se place dans dans le monde de j'aime
pas le mot mais je vais le dire pour
être clair politicien des partis
politiques etc il a été imprudé il est
jugé imprudent il va trop loin on n'a
pas vu chacun dépend un peu son bout de
gras etc mais il faut prendre en compte
la réalité d'aujourd'hui et ça dépasse
tout à fait le destin de d'Emmanuel
Macron je le dis au passage mais le
défi d'aujourd'hui c'est que les
Français sont extrêmement inquiets
sont se posent des questions sur vous
rendez compte même sur l'avenir du pays
la capacité que nous avons ou pas de
continuer à vivre ensemble réponse oui
oui on y arrivera c'est compliqué et
donc en ce sens
c'est un exercice compliqué il veut pas
se laisser pas se laisser tacler par ses
propres amis en disant il va il va avoir
Macron ils ont dû se parler ensemble ou
bien il va proposer ses services mais il
a raison de dire que si ça continue
c'est même même un ton en dessous pas
dramatisé mais si ça devait continuer
étonner la gravité des enjeux il y a un
moment où il faudra quitter les petites
combinades partisane qui ne servent que
certains et il faudra voir la capacité
qu'on a au cours que les uns et les
autres ont pas de effectivement de faire
à la Réunion sacrée ça renvoie des
ça renvoie ça renvoie presque à 14-18
enfin les périodes de très anciennes
mais bon en tout cas c'est sa façon à
lui
j'ai été surpris parce qu'il y a encore
il y a encore trois mois il avait dit je
parlerai pas avant de pratiquement avant
l'entrée dans la campagne présidentielle
de 2027 mais les choses sont graves
union sacrée si sa façon à lui bon il en
laisse la responsabilité de dire c'est
grave et effectivement la situation
d'aujourd'hui elle est jouable on peut
il le dit d'ailleurs on peut relever le
défi mais elle est grave ça vous a
surpris vous aussi pierre parce que
Laurent Wauquiez qui est quand même une
figure chez les républicains présentés
comme le probable le candidat à la
présidentielle par Eric Chiotti qui
appelle qui dit c'est pas une coalition
mais qui appelle quand même à passer un
accord sur les grands textes bah il y en
a eu un contexte juste avant les
événements qui viennent de se produire
ça s'appelle la réforme des retraites il
était où à ce moment-là c'était un grand
texte je veux dire le gouvernement avait
tendu la main monsieur Wauquiez était
tout à fait à l'aise avec la proposition
qui était celle du gouvernement il y a
eu quand même quelques conflits sociaux
dans ce pays on n'a pas beaucoup entendu
donc je trouve venir là aujourd'hui
après quatre jours après une semaine
d'événements inédits en France et
expliquer et faire la leçon sortir du
Platon aller sur des événements
dramatiques les événements inédits et
dramatiques sortis du Platon aller
chercher Bourdieu qu'il n'a pas luderida
qu'il n'a pas lu aller en venir à
Monsieur Clémenceau oui alors vu ce
qu'il dit sur Bourdieu et derrière je
suis pas sûr qu'il ait compris
véritablement le sens du travail et des
travaux de ces grands intellectuels
expliquer que l'état de la France
d'aujourd'hui ce serait la
responsabilité de la gauche et de
Derrida et et Bourdieu c'est c'est quand
même faire des raccourcis bon après le
constat et le sien quand il parle de
désintégration de l'État et de la nation
ça si on est là effectivement bah il y a
plus qu'à faire table rase et mettre
tout le monde autour de la table et à
construire un nouveau projet pour la
France parce que le constat est
tellement apocalyptique mais mais il est
apocalyptique le concept est dressé par
Monsieur Wauquiez et en même temps les
réponses sont les mêmes que l'on connaît
de celle de la droite c'est-à-dire
l'immigration voilà l'immigration c'est
la responsa les responsable c'est la
cause de tous les problèmes notamment
celle des quartiers populaires et puis
la question de l'ordre de la sécurité
voilà voilà le projet de Monsieur
Wauquiez et c'est pour ça que je c'est
pour ça que je m'interroge sur Oui sur
la question sociale qui était celle de
la réforme des retraites parce que c'est
c'est quand même une des préoccupations
principales des Français et Monsieur
Wauquiez a fait a été il aurait dû à
l'époque sortir du bois et être en
première ligne pour parler
avec le projet la gauche sur la
situation dramatique moi je dis
dramatique ou en tout cas très sérieuse
que traverse le pays aujourd'hui je veux
dire on peut contester ce que dit ce que
dit ou ce que a l'air de proposer alors
ok mais que dit la gauche là-dessus
parce que vous dites c'est pas normal et
tous c'est qu'elle est ou bien la
situation de votre point de vue n'est
pas dramatique ou bien alors il y a
d'autres perspectives lesquelles juste
on va voir avant de vous entendre là
parce qu'il met quand même des
conditions Laurent Wauquiez il fait des
propositions en vrai oui il y en a qui
ont déjà été proposés par les
républicains ou même l'exécutif alors je
liste l'expulsion de tous les étrangers
responsables d'actes de violence un choc
carcéral avec des peines minimales de
privation de liberté effective dès le
premier acte de violence aux personnes
de la prison ferme systématique à la
première atteinte à l'intégrité physique
ainsi que la suspension des aides
sociales au délinquants et parents de
délinquants sur ce point à noter il cite
héritier en évoquant cette proposition
donc chose qu'il n'avait pas faite
depuis bien longtemps il demande pour
cela la construction de plus de place de
prison et le retour des peines plancher
enfin il souhaite revenir sur la justice
des mineurs et sur l'excuse de minorité
une proposition qui a déjà été faite par
le RN à la fin des violences urbaines et
balayer par le garde des sceaux dans la
foulée je vous propose d'écouter un
extrait des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
à quel moment allez-vous entendre nos
propositions comme celles de revenir sur
l'excuse de minorité pour les mineurs ou
les allocations familiales pour les
familles de délinquants l'excuse de
minorité si vous y revenez je vous
indique tout de suite que le Conseil
constitutionnel vous censurera monsieur
le député c'est tout à fait clair parce
que le Conseil constitutionnel souhaite
qu'on fasse une différence entre les
mineurs et les majeurs et je pense que
certains peuvent ici retrouver voilà il
y a des propositions est-ce que du coup
ça rend possible un éventuel accord sur
cette texte avec la majorité
présidentielle avec Emmanuel Macron
pierre moi je vais vous faire la même
réponse que celle que je vous avais
faite quand on a parlé de la réforme de
la loi sur la sur les retraites oui il y
a il y a une filiation il y a un même
schéma de pensée entre ce qu'est devenu
le macronie qui était censé marcher sur
ces deux gars de la gauche et la droite
et ce qu'est la droite traditionnelle on
voit bien que la question de la question
de la sécurité la question de
l'immigration est au cœur du des
préoccupations d'Emmanuel Macron et de
son gouvernement le projet de loi asile
l'immigration qui était un peu sur la
table il y a encore quelques semaines
qui va revenir à l'automne et clairement
compatible avec la droite républicaine
je vois absolument pas pourquoi cette
droite là ne se mettrait pas d'accord
avec Emmanuel Macron pour avancer sur
ces questions d'immigration de sécurité
et d'ordre d'ordre national donc je je
crois que cette famille à vocation a
travaillé ensemble c'est c'est ça
relèverait de l'hypocrisie je trouve que
ça ne se fasse pas et les deux ils ont
intérêt à la fois Emmanuel Macron et à
la fois et Laurent Wauquiez Dominique
c'est un marqueur
nous raconter des histoires qui sont pas
d'accord ils sont évidemment d'accord la
question c'est la seule chose le plus le
propos que vous avez que vous avez
résumé au meilleur sens du terme de leur
évoquer un propos très hard et très dur
mais c'est un propos je me retourne à la
situation de décrypter le Laurent
Wauquiez j'aurais pas cru mais après
tout je vais jusqu'au bout c'est un
propos pour négocier je veux dire c'est
pas prendre du Laurent Wauquiez à 100%
et on fait un accord dans ce cas-là le
problème est résolu par définition c'est
essayons de trouver un compromis mais si
jamais la situation française continue à
se dégrader notamment en termes de
sécurité je peux y revenir ça
deviendrait irrésistible vous avez
relevé quand même que dans son interview
il avait quand même un chemin d'espoir
le chemin d'espoir qui est cette fameuse
méritocratie et il va même très loin sur
la méritocratie il dit il faut être il
faut il faut il faut féliciter il faut
encourager les enfants dès le plus jeune
âge LCP qui serait méritocratique c'est
quoi le mérite quand on a 5-6 ans
franchement Dominique non mais c'est
absurde le mérite n'existe pas c'est une
illusion totale et c'est le fantasme de
cette droite qui voudrait faire croire
qu'il y a des enfants qui sont plus
méritants que d'autres c'est
insupportable franchement elle est très
pénible à lire cette interview le mérite
le mérite existe encore
terminé sur de belles images là-dessus
vous serez d'accord demain la Patrouille
de France ouvrira le traditionnelle des
fils aériens sur les Champs-Élysées
alors comment se sont-ils préparés je
n'attends du prése nous emmène sur leur
base à Salon-de-Provence dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône regarde
les fumigènes tricolores fendent le ciel
de Salon de Provence
[Musique]
c'est ici sur la base aérienne 701 que
s'entraîne à l'année la Patrouille de
France qui vient de souffler ses 70
bougies c'est une unité qui est
spécialisée dans la voltige acrobatique
en patrouille ambassade attitude et
au-delà de ce cette mission technique
elle est aussi là pour porter
les ailes françaises et l'excellence à
la française et les valeurs des
aviateurs et des militaires en général
quand on vient l'été la patrouille
enchaîne les meetings et donc les
entraînements pour les préparer ce
jour-là l'unité doit s'entraîner pour un
gala de l'école de l'air et chose rare
elle réalise son briefing en public
préparation mentale
ça nous permet de nous mettre dans notre
bulle on demande pardon de bien couper
vos téléphones portables et d'être le
plus calme possible dans l'unité 8
aviateurs titulaires et le remplaçant se
voit affublé d'un nom de code Atos
numéro T2 1 à 9 qui correspond à leur
position en vol mais aussi à l'état
d'esprit de la patrouille attends c'est
un indicatif tous les escadrons tous les
tous les unités militaires en noir c'est
en référence à la fameuse des devises
des Mousquetaires un pour tous points
voilà l'esprit d'équipe tout son beau
être des pilotes de chasse chevronnées
1500 heures de vol minimum leur repère
son bouleversés au sein de l'unité car
dans les airs ils doivent ne faire qu'un
et au sol apprendre les nouveaux rituels
propres à l'équipe notamment la musique
mais je dégushima
leader va dire tout ce qu'il va dire en
vol et ses équipiers
en même temps à au son de la voie du
leader vont effectuer les gestes qu'il
répéteront ensuite en vol la musique en
fait elle sert aux équipiers à faire le
lien entre la voix du pilote et le geste
c'est vraiment une préparation mentale
qui est essentielle et indispensable au
bon déroulement du vol direction le
tarmac ou attendre les 8 Alpha Jet de la
Patrouille de France un avion très
rustique prisé pour ses aptitudes en vol
alors l'Alphajet c'est à la base c'est
un avion entraînement qui équipe les
forces depuis 1979 ce qu'il caractérise
c'est sa manœuvrabilité même à base
vitesse ce qui permet d'avoir un
spectacle qui est extrêmement proche du
public à la Patrouille de France le
couple pilote mécanicien forme un duo
très soudé le commandant de Cortes dit
charognard c'est ce qu'il doit à son
mécano
c'est le mécanicien qui choisit son
pilote au mois de décembre
et j'ai eu l'honneur d'être choisi par
Alexandre
c'est un avion un mécanicien
[Musique]
les appareils s'élancent
entre 200 et 500 km/h les Alpha Jet vont
réaliser de nombreuses figures ouragan
Concorde Apollo avec ou sans fumigène le
vol est une extrême précision les avions
ne sont qu'à deux mètres les uns des
autres
après 45 minutes dans les airs retour
sur le tarmac charognard peut souffler
le commandant aujourd'hui numéro 4 de la
patrouille sera amené à prendre la place
de leader l'année prochaine un honneur
je mesure et on mesure tous de l'équipe
la chance qu'on a de
d'être ici effectivement c'est une
vieille une vraie fierté déjà de
représenter l'armée de l'air de l'espace
représenter les Français également et
puis déployer le plus grand tricolore le
plus grand drapeau tricolore qu'on
puisse qu'on puisse faire en France et
c'est magnifique il se drapeau sera
déployé demain par la patrouille de
France les fumigènes bleues blancs
rouges viendront comme chaque année
envelopper l'arc de triomphe en
ouverture du défilé du 14 juillet
et voilà pour cette très belle image de
Jonathan duprés avant ce défilé du 14
juillet demain on va passer à la
dernière rue de presse de la saison un
peu particulière vous allez voir
[Musique]
ça vous convient l'honneur de faire la
dernière revue de presse de la saison
oui on va deviner les thèmes en musique
on va commencer par le premier thème
attention ça va aller très vite mais
c'est assez facile je vous propose de
jouer avec moi vous allez deviner le
thème on écoute
si ça part si ça parce que là du coup
ça casse le jeu
[Musique]
les feux d'artifice
qui sont en Une de nombreux quotidiens
ce matin ça commence dès ce soir dans
les plus petites communes soulignent le
Berry républicain qui dresse la liste
des endroits où se rendre pour en
prendre plein les yeux mais Midi Libre
nous rappelle quand même que cette année
les feux d'artifice perdent des couleurs
beaucoup craignent que les violences que
l'on a connu après la mort du jeune Naël
reprennent alors de nombreuses communes
ont choisi d'annuler les festivités
d'autres ont choisi de faire autrement
soit à cause du contexte soit pour des
raisons écologiques l'Alsace nous en
parle aujourd'hui ces alternatives ça
peut être des jets d'eau colorés en
circuit fermé évidemment ou des drones
lumineux et c'est assez bluffant
deuxième thème pareil ça va aller vite
j'espère que vous allez deviner plus
facilement on écoute
[Musique]
sur le blind test on parle du Tour de
France qui poursuit sa route il est
attendu deux pieds ferme dans le Rhône
c'est notre tour titre Le Progrès 21
communes traversées avec une arrivée
spectaculaire à belleville-en-beaujolais
en ligne droite et un peu en montée
l'occasion de bien voir les coureurs des
dizaines de milliers de spectateurs sont
attendus un autre thème peut-être un peu
plus dur celui-là on va voir si vous
avez l'oreille
[Musique]
c'est la revanche la Provence pardon qui
revient 25 ans en arrière avec une
interview de plusieurs champions du
monde Zinédine Zidane évidemment qui a
invité Fabien Barthez big chanter
Lizarazu Didier Deschamps Christian
Karembeu et Bernard Diomède il raconte
leur amitié et ce moment qui a
complètement changé leur vie je citerai
tirée Roland après cela on peut mourir
tranquille le plus tard possible mais on
peut dernier thème on écoute
[Musique]
une sur les vacances aujourd'hui mais
moi ça me permet de vous souhaiter de
très belles vacances
et très belle vacances à tous puisque
c'était la dernière de la saison merci à
merci à Dominique merci à Pierre et
merci à tous les clubs qui sont venus
tout au long de cette saison merci à
tous les chroniqueurs à toutes les
équipes techniques et éditoriales on va
inviter les gens qui sont là ils sont
pas beaucoup à cette levés ce matin
Albert est pas mon petit directeur de
réaction et Alexandre nos stagiaire qui
nous quitte et qu'on merci pour ces pour
ces 6 mois passer à notre côté merci à
tous de nous avoir suivis pour vous
revoir cette émission c'est toujours sur
public sénat.fr tous les thés et je vous
donne rendez-vous à la rentrée on se
retrouve le 11 septembre très bel été à
tous
[Musique]